VINCENZO COLUCCI: Being a
developer is not only to code.
You need to put something
of you, make it personal.
And I think that it gives you
the same power of an inventor.
AARON MARSHALL: I am
in a tiny percentage
of people in the world that can
literally work from anywhere.
And I experienced an
amazing new freedom.
MOR SHANI: Our dream was to be
an amazing and inspiring game
company.
Pirate King was the first game
that we created all in house,
five people just
making the game.
For us, this experience
was very important.
JOHN EARNER: I kind
of realized if I
was going to make mobile games,
the only way I was going to do
it was starting my own studio.
And as a founder, you only
have yourself to blame,
which I find pretty liberating.
JOHAN ATTBY: I saw
a couple of friends
starting their companies.
And I'm super
competitive, so I decided
to leave my career
as a scientist
and become an entrepreneur.
I decided to go for the
biggest hobby, sport fishing.
Fishbrain is a social
network, so anglers globally
can log their catches.
They can share their
catchers, sort of
brag about their catches.
It feels great to be
back in Stockholm again,
because you can actually
develop something here
that is used globally.
MALE SPEAKER 1:
Growing up, I always
wanted to be a medical doctor.
But when I got to
high school, I noticed
that to innovate in a
medical space you need
like 30 years of experience.
But with mobile technology,
I can innovate and actually
generate change in people's
lives a lot faster.
Giftedmom is a social enterprise
to improve maternal and infant
health.
MALE SPEAKER 2: Maternal
mortality, infant mortality
is a worldwide problem.
One of our objectives
is like, not only
to concentrate in Cameroon,
but spread this concept
to other developing countries.
MALE SPEAKER 1: We've noticed
that 70% of smartphone users
across Africa are on Android.
I want to leverage on this to
have a huge number of users.
MALE SPEAKER 2: The beginning
was really an adventure.
But when we built it
up and started testing,
it was really exciting
because the reaction
of those who were using the
app-- all of them were shocked.
It makes me really proud.
And it's also like motivation
to keep moving forward, yeah?
MALE SPEAKER 1: Each
time a woman in this era
just loads the application,
and we see popping up,
Giftedmom, it's like, this
is just it's joy, man.
And you're like, I'm
going to go do better.
AYNUR ABDULNASYROV: I grew
up in a small town called
[? Deartulli. ?] And
then, I understood
that education is
the way to grow,
so I started learning English.
Lingualeo is the next level for
interactive language learning
worldwide.
The first time I saw
somebody using the app,
it was in the Moscow tube.
And it was a real
excitement, because when
you start understanding
that there are like millions
of people who got their English
better because of the app, then
you understand
that it's actually
changed the world a bit.
CHRIS WAWRZINEK:
When I was a child,
I was really inspired
by the combination
of gaming and building things.
I'm a lawyer and work
together with my brother
who is a dentist.
KAI WAWRZINEK: When we
were kids, both of us
were really attached to gaming.
My brother was a
little bit better,
but I could beat
him because I was
the one who was able to
hack the toplists and so on.
So I was kind of
cheating a little bit.
That was kind of the
beginning of my gaming career.
CHRIS WAWRZINEK: We
founded together a company.
And when we started the
company, it was a big step.
We grew out of the garage
of my parents' house
and really professionalized
the company,
getting all the best people
gathered in one place,
and trying to make a
better and a better game.
The vision for us is becoming
one of the world's leading game
companies.
OLIVIER JEANNEL: I grew up
with over 80% hearing loss.
That hasn't stopped me
from doing so many things
in my life.
Being an entrepreneur allows
me to have the sense of freedom
and doing what I want.
And I knew that I could do
something about accessibility
in telecommunications
to deaf people.
Rogervoice is an app that
allows deaf people to make
phone calls.
There's people in
Canada trying the app.
There's people in Kuwait.
There's somebody in Japan.
These people I have never met,
but they're reaching out to me.
And they're like,
I need this app.
And they go onto the
GooglePlay store.
They download it
and they try it out.
And then they e-mail me.
And they are like,
this is amazing.
JOHN EARNER: You walk
into a new place that's
three times the size of
the office we're in now,
and you can't
imagine filling it.
A year and a half
ago, I remember
walking into this office
here in Soho Square
and feeling the same way.
It's both an
exhilarating feeling
to realize that
we've made it so far,
and also there's so far to go.
The Winston Churchill
quote I guess
would be appropriate-- "We're
at the end of the beginning."
MOR SHANI: When we
started Pirate King,
we had 200 installs a day.
Today, we have over
200,000 installs a day.
It's been an incredible journey
for us, growing from 5 people
to 30 people, from small offices
to bigger, improving the team
and bringing more
amazing people.
This is something
really exciting,
and we can't wait to bring more
amazing games to our community
and to the world.
AARON MARSHALL: Around
Over, we have a mantra.
We like to say, go
big and go home.
We don't think you should
be sacrificing your family
in order to make some wealth
or create value or change
the world.
What good is it to have
all of those things
if you don't have a family
to then share in that success
with?
MALE SPEAKER 3: I think
[INAUDIBLE] is actually
the products of [INAUDIBLE]
more exported in the world.
VINCENZO COLUCCI:
Success for me is doing
what you want with your life.
For me, it's living in
my city, with my parents,
with my girlfriend and be happy.
And I can do it by
being a developer.